voilà et pour décrypter analyser c'est
cette guerre en ukraine j'accueille en
plateau notre invité bonjour sylvie
bermann vous êtes ancien ambassadeur de
france en russie merci d'être avec nous
en plateau sur sur france 24 je voulais
en tout d'abord à évoquer avec vous les
derniers mots de vladimir poutine on l'a
vu lors de ses dernières heures il
évoque des nazis des toxicomanes à la
tête de l'ue qu'est né ce que d'une
certaine manière on observe dans sa
pensée à lui mais de manière plus
générale dans la classe dirigeante russe
une sorte de glissement une sorte de
radicalisation de la classe dirigeante
russe selon vous un radicalisation de
vladimir poutine c'est sûr vous évoquez
tout à l'heure les propos de
medvedev ce qui ne sont pas son style et
qui assume cette en disant même ses plus
graves en disant nous n'avons pas besoin
de relations avec les pays occidentaux
et c'est vrai que vladimir poutine a
fait ce choix l'an il l'a imposée aussi
à tous le conseil national de sécurité
parce qu'on a vu des personnalités assez
puissante normalement mal à l'aise les a
fait répéter leurs positions donc je
pense que c'est un choix qui est un
choix personnel avec une forme de
radicalisation sans doute liée à l'
isolement du peu vide aussi et au
ressassement de certaines obsessions
c'est à dire le fait qu' ils ont le
sentiment d'avoir été humiliée et trahie
par l'occident n'est que l'ukraine n'a
pas de raison d'être que c'est une que
c'est une aberration et c'est sans doute
la raison de cette intervention il y a
eu jusqu'à la fin des négociations
diplomatiques le président macron bien
sûr mais également le chancelier
allemand et puis le président en
exercice de l'osce cee avait rencontré
sergueï lavrov aussi donc il y avait
des négociations diplomatiques qui
portait aussi sur les accords de minsk
et à aucun moment il n'a laissé entendre
qu'il allait envahir au contraire il
disait qu nom et lee croyez vraiment
selon vous à ces négociations où c'était
plus d'un mais sûrement pas les
négociations pour la forme et sa
décision dans le faisait déjà baida sa
décision était sûrement prise
effectivement mais ce qui est
intéressant comme j'ai travaillé dans le
cadre du groupe de contact de l'eau
assez haut sur la mise en oeuvre des
accords de minsk c'est que la veille
encore on avait des contacts avec les
ukrainiens qui ne croyait pas à cette
guerre c'est est-ce que ça a été évoqué
également tout à l'heure c'est une
guerre qui ne sera sûrement pas
populaire et sûrement pas dans la durée
les intellectuels les libéraux alors ils
sont peut être minoritaire mais quand
même frappé un pays indépendant de cette
manière là sous des prétextes assez peu
crédible est alors évidemment il ya une
télévision et des médias qui sont sous
contrôle du gouvernement et on l'a vu
ils reçoivent des instructions de
censure d'autres ont dit le journal
novaïa gazeta a dit clairement la russie
bombarde d'ukraine et l'a écrit en russe
et en ukrainien aussi donc je pense
qu'effectivement il ya il ya d'un côté
ce choix qui a été fait 2 on a
l'impression choix un petit peu
obsessionnel ce refus de l'existence de
de l'ukraine et puis de l'autre côté une
opinion publique qui risque d'évoluer si
la guerre dure trop longtemps et en fait
le sentiment était quand ils ont démarré
que ça allait être une guerre rapide
enfin ils n'appellent pas guère eu d une
opération spéciale pour éviter d'avoir
des images de civils tués or aujourd'hui
les ukrainiens résiste oui il résiste
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs mieux que prévu
est ce que comme l'affirmé en gala
merkel s'était en 2014 ou le ton de la
confidence à l'époque elle le disait à
françois hollande il me semble à propos
de vladimir poutine est ce que vous
pensez quand même qu'il a perdu pied
avec la réalité c'est ce qu'elle évoqué
à l'époque madame madame merkel est ce
qu'il ya eu une certaine manière dans la
tête de vladimir poutine il ya eu
un glissement d'une certaine sorte de
déclic si vous voyez ce que je veux dire
probablement et qui est
récent je pense pas qu'il ya trois
quatre ans ils envisageaient de
d'envahir l'ukraine peut-être de
reprendre le dombass de l'annexé à la
russie de reconnaître son indépendance
ça effectivement même s'ils
s'inscrivaient dans le cadre des accords
de minsk peut-être qu'ils ne l'avaient
pas exclu mais de là à
envahir franchir les frontières d'un
état non seulement reconnu par la
communauté internationale mais reconnu
dans ses frontières par par la russie
frappée la ville de kiev qui était une
grande ville russe autrefois est en fait
ils parlent de d'un peuple frère ce
quelqu'un parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
russes qui sont d'origine ukrainienne au
courant de la famille même une grande
partie de l'armée mais russe tout ça
était inimaginable et inimaginable comme
je le disais encore parlé les ukrainiens
la veille est-ce que selon vous la
dîmière poutine email il mène une
certaine manière une guerre idéologique
en ukraine c'est à dire que pas une
guerre une guerre stratégique pour des
conquêtes de territoires ou de
ressources mais une guerre idéologique
pour éviter d'une certaine manière une
contagion des montres des mocratique
dans l'ex pré carré de la russie
soviétique selon vous je pense pas que
ce soit véritablement le sujet le sujet
c'est qu'il ya cette nostalgie à la loi
de l'empiré russe de de la puissance de
l'union soviétique et c'est vrai que
l'ukraine en faisait partie mais que
pour lui qui était officier du kgb au
moment de la chute de l'union soviétique
ça a été un grand choc il avait dit il à
cette nostalgie d'ailleurs à pile à
cette nostalgie en disant que ça avait
été la pire catastrophe du xxème siècle
tout en agitant c'est parce qu'il ya des
populations russe qui se trouve à
l'extérieur de la russie donc il ya
toujours eu ce sentiment en face à cette
volonté de pouvoir
effectivement comme il le dit entre
guillemets protéger les populations
russe mais je pense pas que ce soit de
nature et idéologique et que ce soit
vraiment démocratie contre autoritarisme
d'abord parce que l'ukraine n'est pas
dell non plus en termes de démocratie je
ne sais pas ce qui fait rêver les russes
mais bien sûr que je n'en le sujet c'est
qu'ils considèrent que l'ukraine ne doit
pas exister que ça fait partie de de la
russie c'est ça le vrai problème c'est
même pas un gain territoriales c'est
autre chose et c'est quelque chose qui
est devenu chez lui obsessionnel qui a
été préparé par cette série d'articles
et puis il faut dire qu'au cours de ces
deux dernières années il a vu peu de
monde pas seulement des dirigeants
étrangers mais y compris des russes et
même ses collaborateurs qu'ils voyaient
peu ou à distance et ça favorise
peut-être effectivement une crispation
des dépositions
c'est parce que j'avais un site à des
entretiens entre vladimir poutine et
emmanuel macron à plusieurs reprises et
assez longuement il y avait des sujets
sur lesquels il était en désaccord mais
il y avait une possibilité de discuter
et soit d'obtenir un résultat soit non
mais le président avait obtenu la
rencontre en format enfin le sommet en
format normandie à paris en décembre
2019 avec une première rencontre de
poutine et zelensky donc à cette époque
là il y avait quand même une possibilité
de discuter et là le président macron
l'a dit en rentrant de moscou il est dit
le poutine que j'ai rencontré cette fois
ci n'est pas celui que vous ils étaient
entre 10 et un manque et refermer dans
une sorte de thé rhétorique qui lui est
renvoyé par l'effet d'une série de
manière obsessionnelle et du coup
aujourd'hui alors certes il ya le côté
des informations avec les génocides 2
les
charniers la dénazification mais il est
à craindre qu'il croit lui même à cette
rhétorique
merci beaucoup sylvie bermann d'être
venu sur le plateau pour répondre à
notre question à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes ancien
ambassadeur de france en russie encore
merci à vous